this year I remember you praised it Mr.
you said
that actually
This is the biggest step forward in EU integration.
From years bigger
than the platform did
Mr.
Bosak Just Wants To
for the future European Union
there was just doing different rhetorical splits
Not to mention the opening.
The truth is
We have a very low level of investment.
This problem will continue in our economy.
a funds for investment measures half numerous
that we could have for several hundred days
Does not affect the Polish economy
Incompetence of the ruling camp
The Polish economy needs them.
that we did not fall into the review
Lord of Poland I am selling Polish sovereignty right
The future of Poland is in Europe.
Not in the East
and it would be good
that the confederation
In the special opinion of your colleagues
Mr.
Corwin-Mikke and Mr.
Braun finally got it